when was the moment that Jim called you
guys up and was like okay we're gonna go
what was it like for you it's exciting
yeah it was about 2013. yeah I think I
got a call
saying I think I've figured out how to
extend the story and extend the Family
and extend the world and not just make a
carbon copy of the first one so that's
exciting because we now know we're going
on a different Journey yeah and it
really is about that you know your
family in this one it's so it's so
emotional what I find so fascinating is
the stories about you guys acting
underwater and like was there any point
in there when you're holding your bath
for like three minutes and you've done
an action scene and you have to emote
underwater that you're like how am I
gonna like how am I gonna do am I going
to resurface
um yeah I mean those thoughts go through
your brain and and just like they enter
your thoughts you just have to like let
them kind of transition out of it
because you still you still have to get
that take done and and you surrender you
you you go back to the formula that
worked in the first avatar you follow
your training you use all the tools and
resources that Jim has facilitated
around you and you trust the process and
then what always ends up happening is
that you just have a wonderful
experience does this has this change
your relationship with actually being in
a body of water now if someone says
let's go for a swimming like I'll pass
I'm good
no really to be honest even when he
suggested the idea of it you it's only
now when people are bringing it up does
it seem crazy like to us doing it it
that was the job but yeah look you would
those scenes are hard enough to do on
for actors on dry land yeah let alone 30
feet deep with no oxygen so it's but
when you're doing it you just rely on
each other that's what you're relying on
the tech and the water goes away and
it's about a father and a son or a
mother and a daughter and that's what
you're trying to accomplish that's true
there was a lot of time obviously in
between filming the first one and
filming the second one to see the
response of the public and people want
it to be in like they wanted to be in
that world after their site it was like
nothing people had seen before given
that knowledge what are your hopes for
people's reaction this time around I
think the same I I wouldn't want anymore
or you know obviously I have the hope
that that it just it's just well
received that's that's that's all I want
because it is something very special I
was a part of it and still when I
watched it it's almost like I had I did
not remember that I was a part of it I
was I was experiencing it and it was um
it was something truly magnificent yeah
and as you said it's in that long time
that's there's thousands of people
involved we're small cogs in this thing
at the end of the day and you you just
see how much of a labor of love it is
for Jim and for everyone else involved
on the design team and everything and
you just hope a movie connects and if
the message is about protecting those
that you love that's something I'm sure
that we can relate to yeah absolutely
well congratulations uh we were all very
excited after the movie was done like
that's kick us out of the theater from
chatting about it so it's great yeah and
excited to see the next one thank you